et
bonsoir mesdames bonsoir mes demoiselles
bonsoir messieurs voici le programme qui
vous est proposée sur la première chaîne
ce soir dans un instant vous sera
présentée les soirs puis à 20h30
vous verrez ce soir sur la première
chaîne le premier épisode d'un nouveau
feuilleton gens de la tow miracle qui
vous sera présenté tous les soirs à la
même heure pendant la période des fêtes
il s'agit d'un feuilleton de michel
dorée adapté du roman du comte de
gobineau le prisonnier chanceux réalisé
par jean paul carrel avec dans les rôles
principaux patrick dewaere 8000 à
michael landon robert nous robert 26
alexandre vigneault
jacques balutin et jean paredes ensuite
à 20h50 vous pourrez voir sur la
première chaîne ce soit la bouquetière
des innocents un mélodrame danis et
bourgeois et ferdinand douillet adapté
et réalisé par rouget glisse avec rosy
varte francis claude clos titre et
etienne bierry dans les rôles principaux
à 22h40 toujours sur la première chaîne
pierre tchernia que vous invitera à une
grande émission de variétés dont il est
l'auteur et le réalisateur the cocorico
et nos émissions s'achèveront sur la
première chaîne avec télé nuit qui vous
sera présenté à 23h30 mais donné il me
semble que vous n'êtes pas rayé du
programme de la première chaîne mais oui
vous savez bien nous avions décidé de
changer de chaîne pour les fêtes de noël
et du jour de l'an ce qui permettra
ainsi aux téléspectateurs qu'ils vous
aiment bien de vous voir en couleurs
enquête délicate attention
vous savez aussi que nous retrouverons
tous les soirs pendant tous ces jours de
fête pour parler des programmes
oui je le sais j'en suis ravi alors que
les programmes de la seconde chaîne ce
soir jacqueline et bien sûr la chaîne
que vous abandonnez nous allons être
tout de suite dans l'ambiance de noël en
assistant à la préparation d'un mystère
de noël avec une pièce d'andré aubé qui
se passe en angleterre au xvème siècle
le souffle de minuit adapté par michel
personnes mises en scène par alain
boudés c'est pierre mondy qui tiendra le
rôle principal de cette pièce du théâtre
nous passerons au cinéma à 21h40 avec un
film qui marquera le début du festival
gérard philipe qui durera jusqu'au 31
décembre nous vous présenterons ce soir
la première partie de la chartreuse de
parme de christian jacq vous
la seconde partie demain à 21h10
christian jacq sera entouré de maria
casarès et de rené faure ce film
terminera la soirée il sera à peu près
aux airs voilà et bien je crois que nous
avons parlé du programme de la première
semaine nous vous souhaitons maintenant
une très agréable soirée
à tout à l'heure à tout à l'heure